[Musica]
e ho scelto questa fotografia dove è
riportata una scena di spiaggia e mi
ricordo all'infanzia quando ero bambina
andava al mare di qui sono tuttora pazzo
e mi ricorda mia madre che mi aspettava
Questo ci ricorda
questa era la voce di Stefano un signore
sulla sessantina che ho incontrato a
Cagliari ha raggiunto dopo migliaia di
chilometri pedalate su di una vecchia
bicicletta in un lungo giro in Italia
avevo in mano una foto e mi raccontava
il motivo per cui avesse scelto proprio
quella
ed abbiamo immaginato a tutti quella
fotografia attraverso le sue parole vero
abbiamo creato Tutti nello stesso
identico aumento un'immagine nella
nostra testa
è bastato ascoltare poche evocative
parole perché noi potessimo
letteralmente creare una fotografia Anzi
centinaia e centinaia di fotografie
tutti diverse tra loro
è questo un semplice esempio di
moltiplicazione di immagine che è
direttamente proporzionale al numero di
persone che avranno una relazione con
essa in qualsiasi modo e in qualsiasi
luogo
ogni momento della nostra vita creiamo
immagini generiamo istantanee che vanno
a
caricare la nostra memoria e il nostro
vissuto
ed è per questo che creiamo immagini per
ricordare conoscere e riscoprire
costantemente chi siamo
è incontestabile oggi la bulimia di
immagini alla quale siamo sottoposti
volenti e non ogni secondo Ci viene
richiesto di immagazzinare migliaia di
input fotografici che però
fisiologicamente non riusciamo a gestire
non riusciamo nemmeno più a vedere e
questa assuefazione crea intorno
all'immagine una graduale perdita di
valore un abbattimento che mette sullo
stesso piano tempo memoria e ricordi
l'esperienza visiva è assillante
dovete sapere che io sono un fotografo
che ha smesso di fotografare
che non ho mai spesso però nemmeno per
un secondo di amare le immagini
qualche anno fa mi sono chiesto che
senso avesse riempire il mondo di nuovi
fotografie in questo particolare
contesto storico nel quale tutti noi
siamo immersi così caotico e alienante
e da dove poter ripartire allora da dove
poter ricominciare
la risposta è arrivata da vecchi
fotografi dimenticate abbandonate
sono fotografie che raccoglievo già da
tempo dai mercatini dell'antiquariato
centinaia di
immagini di persone di volti di persone
di luoghi conosciuti e sconosciuti
di scene di vita quotidiana
ho capito fin da subito che avevano un
valore quello del ricordo che era attiva
nel momento in cui erano custodite
all'interno dell'album fotografico e
riconosciuto questo valore da una
piccola cerchia di persone che
gravitavano intorno a queste immagini
cioè la famiglia come testimone di
questo ricordo visivo
Poi però le persone muoiono I custodi
dell'album fotografico non esistono più
i nomi si dimenticano e volti si
cancellano prima nella memoria che sulla
carta stessa si perde il valore di
quelli identità rappresentate arrivano
sui banchi di mercatini mischiate fra
loro vendute a peso su aste online
offerte collezionisti perse arrivano a
noi come fotografie inutili
capito allora il grande valore latente
che queste fotografie portavano con sé
mi sono chiesto in che modo potente
riattivare In che modo poter dare loro
un valore nuovo
ho cominciato così ad intervenire
fisicamente su di esse con dei tagli
sovrapponendole cercando un dialogo tra
di loro le coperte con i colori acrilico
il risultato però seppur a volte
visivamente piacevole non era mai una
vera e propria riattivazione perché
veniva attraverso un processo
troppo mediato dal mio modo di vedere
dal mio modo di pensare il risultato
Cioè alla fine era un semplice
raccontare di me
capi allora che la vera risposta non
stava nel cercare un nuovo valore ma ne
riprende il motivo stesso per cui Esso
furono create la memoria
attuale con le canne alloggi al qui e
ora ricaricare le immagini di nuovi
significati che non mi appartenevano che
io non potevo e dovevo veicolare
ho capito che c'era un solo e unico modo
per poter riattivare questa fotografia
attraverso il dono donandone alle
persone
lasciare che ogni persona scegliesse la
propria foto da portare via con sé
un'immagine che rievoca negli occhi di
chi lavora custodire Magari il punto di
una persona cara un luogo conosciuto una
memoria che ritorna alla luce un legame
immediato e familiare
basta questo link per poter riattivare
queste fotografie ricaricandole di nuove
significati naturalmente slegati dal
motivo per cui esse furono create la
memoria torna viva e presente le persone
diventano i nuovi album fotografici
pronti ad accogliere questi nuovi
ricordi ed io invece diventa un semplice
attivatore di un processo del quale non
ho più controllo che vive attraverso gli
altri e grazie agli altri mesto ad
osservare da spettatore
ho voluto arrivare a più persone
possibili per poter riattivare più
fotografie possibili
ed è così che nasce fotografie inutili
archivio fotografico ciclo diffuso un
progetto una performance un viaggio in
Italia tre mesi di esplorazione dentro e
fuori di me 4000 km
su di una vecchia bicicletta
Sono partito da Verona una mattina
piovosa appena dopo Pasqua e ho
cominciato a scendere verso sud
Marche Abruzzo Puglia e poi Calabria
Sicilia Sardegna da dove poi ho preso un
traghetto che mi ha portato nell'altra
costa dell'Italia
Campania Lazio Toscana e suffino a
ritornare in pianura padana in piena
estate da dove ero partito
e tutto ciò dovete sapere che non sono
un ciclista
sono una persona però che si fa molte
domande l'ennesima che mi Posi fu In che
modo poter arrivare a tutte queste
persone
ho cominciato a ragionare Allora sul
movimento che hanno queste fotografie la
loro essere custodite all'interno di un
album fotografico a un certo punto
cominciano ad andare finendo sul tavolo
del mercatino da dove poi io le raccolgo
le porto a casa per il fine andarle a
donare alle persone che levano
riattivare
In che modo poter Allora continuare
questo movimento come poterlo
interpretare Come poter spostare
fisicamente queste fotografie
la risposta è stata ahimè una bicicletta
e non una bici qualunque ma una bici da
corsa del 1972 dimenticata e abbandonata
per più di 40 anni in un garage appeso
al muro anche se è diventata inutile ma
pronta per essere riattivata un mezzo
che idealmente può continuare questo
movimento ma che soprattutto può farlo
percepire a me stesso pedalata dopo
pedalata km dopo km
nel progetto coinvolto musei enti e
fondazioni d'arte che sono diventati
punti di arrivo e di aggregazione per
decine e decine di persone
login nei quali Ho ritenuto di poter
valorizzare al meglio il semplice Gesto
da donare
arrivavo mi presentavo raccontavo
quello che stavo facendo e così
centinaia di persone hanno deciso di
attivare centinaia di fotografie
scegliendole
raccontandosi e ho ascoltato Ognuno di
loro ho raccolto e registrato un audio
del motivo per cui avessero scelto
quella precisa fotografia creando così
un grande archivio sonoro che ancora
oggi è di ascoltandolo ritrovo il
viaggio attraverso gli accenti delle
persone da nord a sud isole comprese
ho voluto Inoltre tenere traccia di ogni
donazione attraverso una foto che ho
fatto ad ogni persona con la foto scelta
davanti al viso
questi due grandi archivi sonoro e
visivo alla fine hanno creato un unico
grande
anarchivio questo viaggio è stato tante
cose tutte insieme
un'avventura Certo è stato silenzio è
stato
solitudine una solitudine che non mi ha
mai abbandonato che mi ha
per così dire protetto una bolla nella
quale mi ci sono coccolato che mi ha
accompagnato Nelle tante ore passato da
solo ma insieme a tutto nello stesso
momento
ancora oggi
ripenso a come è stato
così
emozionante Vivere il momento presente
in maniera Così costante un Qui è ora
che non avevo mai provato prima ero lì e
da nessun'altra parte
e come è stato difficile poi tornare a
casa
di colpo non pedalare più rompere quella
routine fatta di sveglia all'alba di
dure salite ma anche dolcissime discese
di pranzi consumati lungo il ciglio
della strada il mare è sempre a sinistra
spesso di un blu che non avevo mai visto
prima come è stato strano ritrovarmi di
colpo
alla cassa alla cassa del supermercato
in fila
per tutti quei 4.000 km ho pensato che
quella fosse la vita vera
ritornai a casa il suo realmente il
giorno in cui KB che invece quel viaggio
non fa altro che un'esaltazione della
vita reale una moltiplicazione di
emozioni che mi ero inconsciamente
costruito km dopo km
la vita vera è questo momento in cui vi
sto parlando è qui e ora
questo viaggio è stato tante cose è
stato
un grande viaggio di relazione è stato
un viaggio di condivisione
e nulla sarebbe successo senza le
persone
esistono tante fotografie inutili 7
gentili con loro
raccontano e portano possa ricordi che
certo non ci appartengono ma nei quali
Sicuramente potremmo riconoscerci fate
le vostre diventate i nuovi album
fotografici custoditele gelosamente
quelle memorie quelle nostre memorie mai
potranno essere memorie inutili
Grazie
[Applauso]